CBS News has learned the Trump
administration is now planning to close
the southern border today - all
non-essential travel meanwhile lawmakers
are working on a plan to give cash to
Americans taking a financial hit that is
a lot of people the president is also
pushing the FDA to fast-track the drugs
to treat the virus we should Jang
reports from the White House on that it
could be a game-changer
president Trump rejected optimism on
Thursday when he announced a drug called
chloroquine commonly used to treat
malaria had been approved by the FDA to
e symptoms of corona virus it's been
around for a long time so we know that
if it if if things don't go as planned
it's not going to kill anybody but FDA
Commissioner Stephen Han quickly
clarified that even though chloroquine
is approved as a malaria treatment the
drug must still go through clinical
tests to see if it's safe to use for
coronavirus so far no drug is
specifically approved for treating it
even though there are several candidates
we may have the right drug but it may
not be in the appropriate dosage form
right now and that may do more harm than
good on Capitol Hill Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell unveiled a
trillion-dollar financial aid package to
help small businesses and industries
like the airlines that are hemorrhaging
money the proposal would also send
direct payments to many Americans up to
$1200 per person and 2400 per couple we
need to take bold and swift action as
soon as possible but there are lawmakers
on both sides of the aisle opposed to
the idea of giving out cash arguing it's
a short-sighted solution I don't think
that's a good idea now can't stimulate
something that's padlocked and Democrats
were quick to criticize the gops plan
for prioritizing large corporations over
individuals it provides a bailout for a
number of industries again we have to
put the workers first the White House
announced last night that the g7
gathering of world leaders that was
scheduled to take place at Camp David in
June will now be held over video
conference instead Tony like so many
other conferences these days we should
thank you very much